Guten morgen tim.
Ich habe mich schon gewundert ich bin heute fünf gefahren da lag überall strom.
Aux
Logbuch netzpolitik nummer dreihundertdreiundvierzig vom siebenundzwanzigsten april zwanzig zwanzig ja und wie man sich bettet so liegt man würde ich sagen.
Hallo.
Ja und wir haben einen gast dabei nämlich den thomas hallo thomas.
Moin denn wir waren ja schon versprochen wir wollen heute mal wieder erfahren wie es so im süden so aussieht in österreich hast du auch auch schon eine maske auf.
Jetzt zuhause nicht aber ich habe schon eine ganze kollektion von selbst genähten sogar wie wir haben vom verein welche bekommen und ganz viel kreativität schon in die masken.
Also mein lokaler t-shirt produzent hat ja auch schon die erste werbung geschaltet man könnte jetzt auch sein eigenes logo auf einem auf stoff masken drucken lassen und sowas geht voll ab mit dem merch vielleicht wäre das ja was für euch was soll ich noch was.
Ja du wir haben da schon modelle die die die goldmitgliedschaften masken statt t-shirts.
Das wäre vor kurzer zeit noch undenkbar gewesen jetzt.
Österreich ist ein land mit vermummungsverbot also das ist ein radikaler akt da irgendwie mit maske herumzulaufen ich freue mich schon auf die ersten schönen demos mit abstand und mit maske.
Die neue burger diskussion und so das wird lustig.
Es wird ja ein träumchen in einem in einer welt in der du an jeder ecke mit werbung zugeballert wird es jetzt demnächst irgendwelche leute rumrennen zu haben die dann auch noch werbung sich selbst ins gesicht hängen.
Ja das ist wirklich das letzte.
Das ist wirklich unnötig ich bekomme von kohlen pott übrigens eine gesichtsmaske mit logbuch netzpolitik aufdruck das ist natürlich was anderes.
Das was anderes wird ganz was anderes.
Ja das ist ja nicht anders als t-shirts man kann sich da ja auch so identitätspolitik positionieren.
Ach ja identitätspolitik positionieren ja das können wir ja auch mal probieren
war irgendwas linus ist irgendwas passiert in den letzten zwei tagen nachdem wir die letzte sendung veröffentlicht haben.
Ja es hat sich einiges getan über dieses wochenende da ist eine entscheidung gefallen ich glaube mit der hat niemand gerechnet,
wahrscheinlich auch diejenigen die die entscheidung getroffen haben nicht unbedingt denn sie wurde,
offenbar irgendwie am samstag getroffen und dann irgendwie in der nacht zu sonntag verkündet und zwar hat sich die bundesregierung entschieden nun.
Eine marschrichtung vorzugeben bei den.
Contact tracing apps und zwar in richtung eines dezentralen modells bis dahin war die situation dass die bundesregierung sehr klar für ein zentrales modell.
Gesprochen hat und gestimmt hat es wurde wir haben jens spahn mit so zitaten weil irgendwie sagt so was jetzt wollen die leute auf einmal apple und google vertrauen dann sind die daten bei apple und google ja also auch wirklich.
Zeugt auch ein bisschen davon dass er vielleicht nicht ganz die kern der debatte bis zu dem zeitpunkt durchdrungen hatte.
Jetzt irgendjemand hat ihn jetzt durchdrungen bundesregierung hat sich entschieden dezentrales system eine finde ich absolut bemerkenswerte entscheidung.
Und eine richtige entscheidung ganz kurz nochmal worum ging es.
Die systeme zentral und dezentral unterscheiden sich darin wo die entscheidung getroffen wird.
Eine nutzerin alarmiert wird oder nicht und im dezentralen modell passiert das auf dem telefon und im zentralen modell,
passiert das auf einem zentralen server deswegen,
ist das dezentrale modell oder ein vorteil des dezentralen modelles ist es dass also diese entscheidung auf den geräten passiert und somit sehr viel weniger daten an der zentralen stelle aggregiert werden und,
außerdem im dezentralen modell diese zentralen zentral gesammelten daten immer auch veröffentlicht werden das heißt es gibt keinen.
Zentralen allwissenden server oder zentralen server mit wissensvorsprung.
Irgendwelche geheimnisse hätte dir beschützen muss sondern es gibt einfach geräte die einen wissens haben und auf dem.
Selber entscheidungen treffen.
Warum hatte die regierung überhaupt jemals auf einen zentralen ansatz gesetzt auch das habe ich hier schon mal geschildert primär hat der zentrale ansatz zwei versprechungen.
Das eine ist.
Das system kann vergleicht er verbessert werden wenn man weiß wie es operiert welche entscheidung es trifft auf welcher basis und daraus quasi an bessere aktuellere modelle machen kann ja also,
zum beispiel die schwellen hoch oder runter setzt für die dauer eines kontakte oder sowas ja und das zweite.
Das monitoring der pandemien wo ja die bundesregierung dass und ungefähr auch jeder letztendlich sogar pavel ja für seine modelle die er dann in uk w rechnet sich freuen über über,
aktuellere schnellere daten und einblicke das waren die beiden möglichkeiten die sich zweifelsohne im zentralen ansatz leichter.
Realisieren ließen die aber eben zum hohen preis kommen dass man einen zentralen ansatz hat welche entscheidung wurde jetzt getroffen.
Ich denke eine richtig sehr richtige und sehr kluge nämlich zu sagen wir machen das dezentrale modell für.
Die nutzerinnen und nutzer das modell was so daten sparsam wie möglich ist bei dem es keine zentrale überwachung gibt wo die autonomie der entscheidung auf deinem gerät ist und.
Wir geben dir die möglichkeit durch eine zusätzlich zu aktivierende.
Mit deiner einwilligung versehene nennen wir sie mal telemetrie funktion daten zur verbesserung der app und.
Zur besseren zum besseren monitoring der pandemien.
An beispielsweise des zu schicken eine zusatzfunktion die du freiwillig aufgrund deiner persönlichen neigung und autonomen entscheidungsgrundlage aktivieren oder deaktivieren kannst.
Peggy ist die ausgeschaltet ja das ist doch wirklich mal so löst man so ein problem weil im prinzip gab's hier und das hat hast du auch in der.
Verhärtung dieser diskussion gesehen es gab hier zwei lager die du nicht unter einen hut bekommen kannst,
wenn du nur einen der beiden ansätze verfolgt das eine sind menschen die sagen jedes,
alles der datenschutz ist allem unterzuordnen was der bekämpfung dieser pandemien gilt der datenschutz gilt ohnehin nicht infektionsschutz gesetz und so weiter also habt euch nicht so wir machen jetzt hier.
Eine fette zentrale datenbank und dann haben wir eine geile app ja dem gegenüber andere leute die sagen hier pass auf diese zentrale samt datensammlung ist für die basis und für die kernfunktionen dieser app überhaupt nicht notwendig und für die akzeptanz ist es wichtig
daten sparsam und datenschützern vorzugehen deswegen bevorzugen wir den dezentralen ansatz und die haben.
Sehr klar miteinander gerungen weil jeweils die eine seite sich nicht die lösung der anderen aufoktroyiert lassen wollte weil sie eben darin eine bevormundung gesehen hat die ihr nicht gefiel.
Mal ganz ganz objektiv,
geschildert vor dem hintergrund dass natürlich sehr klar ist dass ich hier seit einem monat für den dezentralen ansatz werbe,
und mich gerade sehr daran darüber freue dass diese entscheidung so getroffen ist jetzt wird also gesagt du hast wir haben dezentralen ansatz und wenn du mehr daten preisgeben möchtest für den guten zweck.
An die vertrauenswürdige stelle dann kannst du das als informierte bürgerin tun oder sein lassen und dann kann man sehen.
Was dabei rauskommt ich finde diesen schritt enorm wichtig und ich habe das auch in den einigen presse-interview so gesagt weil das dezentrale modell da musst du dem betreiber nicht vertrauen,
und das ist genau.
Das vertrauen bildende signal zu sagen du musst uns nicht vertrauen deswegen kannst du es in einem zentralen modell ist die aussage du musst uns vertrauen
und wenn jemand sagt ich muss dir ich muss dir vertrauen dann ist die gleiche frage kann ich es denn und eigentlich nicht ja vertrauen ist gut.
Kontrolle ist besser und in dezentralen modell ist die entscheidung bei den nutzerinnen und nutzer.
Insofern ist das wirklich sehr schön wie das hier entschieden wurde ich habe durch einige gespräche noch so ein.
Eine andere perspektive auf den verlauf dieser app entwicklung und dieser diskussion gehabt die ich eigentlich gerne auch nochmal schildern würde und zwar.
Wenn normalerweise die bundesregierung sagt wir machen jetzt einen softwareprojekte dann schreiben die irgendwie ein pflichtenheft.
Dann schreibt dann haben sie dann nach ein paar monaten fertig dann wird das projekt ausgeschrieben dann hast du da irgendeine bieterverfahren und dann gewinnt irgendein bieter das projekt das ist dann im zweifelsfall systems die,
verkaufen geben reichen es wieder runter in irgendwelche outsourcing buden weil sie selber nicht hinkriegen
und dann wird das projekt über einen zeitraum von drei vier jahren einfach kaputt geredet und in sand gesetzt und am ende hast du demo ja und,
genau mit dem ansatz kann man natürlich so eine contact tracing app nicht machen und was die bundesregierung hier offenbar getan hat ist das ja quasi gesagt hat okay,
wir gucken mal wer da hinkommt und wenn du auf einmal was vielversprechendes ist ja wo zum beispiel irgendwie paar helmut sitution paar frauenhofer und irgendwie bekannte deutsche wirtschaftsunternehmen dranhängen.
Dann schmeißen wir da einfach ein bisschen förderkurse drauf und dann wird das dann haben wir mal einen agilen ansatz in der softwareentwicklung ich kann mir vorstellen dass auch die bundesregierung nicht ganz so happy war dann eben zu sehen,
dass die ganze sache irgendwie in einem in einem streit der gruppen und aufsplitterung des projektes und irgendwelchen gegenseitigen vorwürfen.
Auf twitter und den ton geendet ist insofern kann ich mir vorstellen dass das.
Durchaus jetzt auch von seiten der regierung einfach mal die die notwendigkeit erkannt wurde hier jetzt mal ein machtwort zu sprechen bevor eine weitere politische diskussion.
Jetzt vollständig die akzeptanz zerstört gleichzeitig habe ich in der letzten sendung gesagt.
Habe ich ja noch befürchtet dass die bundesregierung sich auf den zentralen ansatz versteift.
Und eine konfrontation mit google und apple sucht.
Die natürlich ebenfalls äußerst problematisch geworden wäre weil sie.
Weil diese konfrontation eben niemanden weiter gebracht hätte man wünscht sich natürlich,
eine konfrontation der staaten mit google und apple man wünscht wünscht sich natürlich auch 'ne 'ne ganz andere nicht so eine duopole markt struktur in den mobilen geräten da sind eine ganze menge sachen,
die da in diesem bereich schief laufen ja aber diese auseinandersetzung war jetzt nicht die schlacht in in die,
die zu führen irgendjemanden weitergebracht hätte ja das sind ganz andere viel tief tiefer greifende probleme.
Leider hat man jetzt natürlich einige leute die dadurch dass von der von seiten der bundesregierung schon das dezentrale modell eben als der google apple ansatz gebranntmarkt wurde hat man jetzt einige leute da die,
ja ich habe heute auch schon so ein paar e-mails bekommen von leuten die,
fernsehbeitrag gesehen haben das passiert ja also es gehört zu den freuden und.
Segnungen wenn man irgendwie in einer reichweiten starken nachrichtensendung vorkommt dass man danach dann halt so ein paar sag mal.
Philosophische abhandlungen von einigen leuten zugesendet bekommt.
Die sich jetzt irgendwie von der bundesregierung an apple und google verkauft fühlen dazu ist leider wirklich traurig zu sagen wenn ihr ein android handy in der tasche habt und wenn ihr ein.
Oder wenn ihr ein apple-handys in der tasche habt dann habt ihr die entscheidung über das vertrauen in diese betreiber.
Getroffen es ist für eine sämtliche apps sei es was weiß ich wats-mann signal euer e-mail clint oder eine corona app oder was auch sonst.
Macht.
Basis die euch da als betriebssystem bereitgestellt wird ist immer in der lage alle eure schutz vor vorkehrungen und wünsche und schutz vorstellungen schutzbedürftig zu unterwandern das heißt.
Die haben euch leider eh schon an den haaren ja und das ist ein zustand den ich jetzt nicht befürworte,
aber das ist eben ein zustand der in dieser debatte schlecht angeführt werden kann zumindest solange apple und google eben ein dezentralen ansatz fahren und ich denke deren entscheidung wird ganz klar gewesen sein.
Pass mal auf wenn wir jetzt hier in kürzester zeit so eine app aus dem aus dem boden stampfen dann wollen wir uns nicht an den daten die finger verbrennen dafür.
Da passen wir mal ein bisschen auf wir haben das in dem offenen brief den der c am freitag noch mitgezeichnet hat formuliert als.
Google und apple sonst nicht scheu daten ihrer nutzer zu sammeln haben selbst die haben hier den dezentralen ansatz gewählt.
Ich habe wie gesagt begrüße diese entscheidung sehr möchte aber natürlich auch darauf hinweisen dass diese entscheidung einen,
der zehn prüfsteine betrifft die wir als c benannt haben und dieser eine,
ist aber ein sehr wichtiger und richtungsweisender denn was du,
mit einem dezentralen ansatz quasi alles gewinnst und schon mal nicht mehr falsch machen kannst ist sehr viel,
im vergleich zu einem zentralen ansatz wir haben noch neun andere prüfsteine die sind natürlich genauso wichtig für viele davon bin ich zuversichtlich dass die auch erfüllt werden und der in erfüllung ist allgemein einfacher,
in einem dezentralen ansatz also ein echt ein überraschender politischer erfolg und.
Heute morgen noch mit einem bekannten darüber gesprochen der meinte so irgendwie komisch normalerweise setzt ihr euch doch nie durch vor allem wenn ihr gegen wirtschaftliche interessen antretet.
Und da habe ich ehrlich gesagt gemerkt so okay ja klingt gelingen das sind wir sind hier nicht wirklich gegen wirtschaftliche interessen angetreten.
Die wirtschaftlichen das wirtschaftliche interesse war immer diese app zu haben weil die eben als heilversprechen gesehen wird auch da wird es sicherlich noch,
einige korrekturen in der erwartungshaltung geben müssen aber ja wahrscheinlich konnten wir uns hier politisch durchsetzen weil wir eben nicht.
Gegen wirtschaftliche interessen angetreten sind tim wie siehst du das denn mit den hals versprechen.
Die die gesellschaft mit dieser app so hat.
Na ich denke es gibt immer noch viel zweifel an der wirksamkeit.
Da gibt's die technische perspektive da gibt's die gesellschaftliche perspektive die kann man haben
das ist okay aber ich denke es ist halt auf jeden fall den versuch wert man im schlimmsten fall hat man halt nichts gewonnen aber eben auch nichts verloren und das ist vielleicht auch das elegante an dieser dezentralen lösung,
dass wir eben jetzt nicht in so einem risiko reingehen müssen dafür
das risiko ist extrem gering weil man das schlimmsten fall stellen wir fest so ja bringt gar nichts oder macht noch alles irgendwie schlimmer war eine scheiß-idee dann wird es in dem betriebssystem als funktionalität wieder ausgeschaltet und dann war's das und man kann aber eben jetzt auch mal damit arbeiten und versuchen
das gewinnbringend zum einsatz zu bringen und bin da ehrlich gesagt ganz optimistisch dass das auch gelingen kann ob das so sein wird.
Ich denke ja einen aspekt den wir hier würde ich uns auf jeden fall auch zur last legen zumindest unterbelichtet haben.
Ist wir haben schon so ein bisschen gesehen diese app als potenzielle sagt sanktionen wenn du dich erstmal dreimal hintereinander zwei wochen weggeschlossen hat weil ohne dass du korona hast weil du neben der falschen person
dir den strohhaufen im im im bus geteilt hast.
Dann wird die akzeptanz sinken ich denke natürlich es gibt durchaus auch potentiale wenn die app quasi dein ticket zum.
Test wird die.
Alle berichten oder oder was heißt alle berichten aber viele berichten von den problemen wenn sie verdacht auf eine corona infektion haben einen test zu bekommen du hattest das mit rudi glaube ich da mal besprochen.
Und auch von vielen anderen leuten hört man das das wäre natürlich auch so eine ganz coole sache wenn die app dir bei der alarmierung direkt so ein code oder sonst was gibt und dann kannst du zum drive in test.
Ja selbstverständlich.
Zum zum gegebenen zeitpunkt wenn wenn wenn die app errechnet hat pass mal auf so zu ab diesem zeitpunkt müsstest du jetzt müsste man das jetzt bei dir nachweisen können.
Herzlichen glückwunsch du kannst so zu drive in testung fahren.
Genau dann kann das könnt ihr diese app dabei noch helfen indem sie halt irgendwo einen code macht den man dann in der test stelle abscannen kann wo drauf steht so ja das hat die,
hier auch wirklich jetzt belegt so das ist jetzt das stimmt und die medizinische adviser in dem fall ist halt das und das also was jetzt so der tag und so weiter betrifft ja da so kann man sich auch gar nicht erst groß vertun sondern man
kann das eben auch sofort aufnehmen sind alles so das sind die ganzen sachen wo es durchaus optimierungspotenzial für den kompletten manuellen tracking,
weg gibt schnellere benachrichtigungen schnellere testern langung weniger oberhaid für das ganze übertragen relevanter daten in diesem prozess und ich denke dass diese angst dass
daraus so eine zwangsarbeit entsteht das geistert ja auch die ganze zeit rum da also die teile ich nicht weil,
wenn man sich halt genau anschaut kann diese app nichts beweisen sie kann nichts belegen man kann nicht belegen dass man daran teilnimmt im eigentlichen sinne man kann aber auch vor allem nicht beweisen dass man da dass man irgendwie gesund ist oder,
oder krank ist nichts dergleichen ist wirklich möglich deswegen
natürlich gibt's irgendwelche cdu-politiker von hinterdupfing hinter vor dem wald die jetzt irgendwie gleich auf solche ideen kommen weil sie wahrscheinlich dieses ganze konzept noch überhaupt nicht richtig verstanden haben weil sie sich
irgendeine vorstellung davon machen was das vielleicht unter umständen sein könnte weil sie davon aus.
Und weil die sich auch ganz ehrlich es gibt ja so so reflex antworten ja und ich glaube bei bei bestimmten cdu-politikern es ist bei jeder ordnungsmaßnahmen pflicht und überall auch einfach eine standard standard reaktion.
Ja du weißt doch gar nicht wie wie gefragt wurde ja also es kann ja auch sein dass du schon schon die journalisten in dem moment so impliziert in dieser frage so wenn lebensläufen gerettet werden könnten wenn die wenn die ganze.
Müssen die linken demonstranten weggeprügelt werden.
Für die bevölkerung vor der ausrottung gerettet werden würden sie dann vielleicht dazu sagen dass es eine zwangsabgaben sollte ja selbstverständlich wir müssen ja die bevölkerung retten so läuft das halt normalerweise und dann springen andere gleich wieder auf den zug auf.
Dieses playbook hat ja leider auch in der vergangenheit gut für sie funktioniert wenn du irgendwie so terrorgefahr hast solange man grundrechte einschränkt wird schon was gebracht haben.
Also die effektivität der maßnahme wird nicht an dem was sie bringt gemessen sondern an dem aufschrei aus der datenschutz community und manche glauben halt auch dass sie damit jetzt hier politisches kleingeld schlagen können.
Kostet leider menschenleben.
Ich wäre auch ich werde vorsichtig das so abzutun also der es ist auf jeden fall gerade ein großer wichtiger.
Etappensiege errungen worden in dieser auseinandersetzung aber diese auseinandersetzung wird noch sehr lange gehen und dein vertrauen dass da jetzt von bestimmten.
Politischen kreisen keine dämlichen ideen mehr rein gestreut werden das habe ich inzwischen ein bisschen verloren.
Wer soll das vertrauen haben ich.
Klang so.
Nein nein nein nein nein das auf gar keinen fall dann ist da habe ich überhaupt gar kein vertrauen selbstverständlich werden dann noch bekloppte weitere ideen reingegossen werden da haben wir jetzt ein paar von abgewehrt und natürlich ist auch diese
pseudonymen datenerfassung von der jetzt die rede ist wird der nächste zankapfel sein das ist ja vollkommen klar weil man auch da sehr viel modernere methoden zum einsatz bringen könnte etcetera und natürlich wird in dieser app irgendwas kaputt sein
ja also da gibt's noch eine ganze menge verpackungsmaterial das wird auch kommen andererseits das war jetzt nicht meine aussage meine aussage war es gibt etwas was man hier,
positiv erreichen könnte das muss man anstreben natürlich müssen wir diesen prozess auch weiterhin kritisch begleiten.
Wer übrigens auch den prozess kritisch begleitet hat ist ja thomas.
In österreich denn da hatten wir ja in der letzten sendung auch schon drauf hingewiesen dass sich apple center works dort die korona die dieses land ja schon hat.
Angeschaut hat eine analyse veröffentlicht hat und.
Da sind wir doch jetzt mal sehr gespannt auf einblicke in in eine nation die schon eine korona app geschafft hat.
Ich glaube was man in dem fall wirklich ganz ganz,
also was spannend sein könnte für andere länder ist die praktische erfahrung dadurch dass wir so eine app jetzt schon seit märz im einsatz haben und die debatte an was konkreten geführt wird und nicht an abstrakten design konzepten.
Gibt es da vielleicht ein paar sachen die ganz relevant sein können ganz kurz zu chronologie also so um den siebten märz herum war entwicklungsbegleitung,
das österreichische rote kreuz die hier sehr zentral für die krisenbewältigung sind waren auftraggeber dieses projekts haben eine spende von der unikat privat stiftung bekommen das ist eine,
versicherung eine private und die haben dann diese kohle an accenture gegeben diesen globalen beratungsinstanz tut
die mit der entwicklung der app bekommen haben und wenn man sich zurück erinnert anfang märz war,
noch überhaupt nichts davon der debatte wie wie sie sich heute darstellt mit zentralen konzept vor allem pepic und dezentralen konzept soweit war die debatte nochmals einfach noch nicht.
Und exzellenter ist da halt einfach hergegangen mal gleich irgendwie zu microsoft und dort in der cloud was zu husten begonnen und mit dieser app entwickelt die idee war von anfang an.
Kontakttraining zu machen und auch einen symptom jacke.
Und in der ersten version hatte sie nur eine manuelle handschake das heißt das ding hat nicht im hintergrund mit allen geräten mit denen du in kontakt bist und und unter einem unter zwei metern irgendwie über fünfzehn minuten lang
in physischen kontakt warst einen handshake gemacht aus einer verbindung ausgelöst sondern es musste wirklich manuell passieren aber über bluetooth energy und ultraschall
ultraschall hätte den vorteil dass es eben nicht durch wände geht sprich ein bisschen besser das abbildet was wir hier auch im infektionsgefahr gehen,
technisch abbilden wollen.
Direkt eine interessierte zwischenfrage hätte den vorteil oder ist es auch realisiert worden.
Ja war in der ersten version oder ist jetzt glaube ich immer noch für den manuellen händchen im einsatz ist auch teil des google dir bei framework dass sie an der stelle verwendet haben.
Ganz kurz weil mich nämlich also diese ultraschall des o interessant sie ja sein mag würde ich mich vor der debatte.
Würde ich mich auf die debatte freuen wenn so eine app dann sagt wir brauchen zugriff auf das mikrofon.
Schauen die app store von android und apple rein das ist das hauptsächliche kommentare menschen oh mein gott wieso braucht die zugriff aus mikrofon ich habe sofort wieder die installiert also ist ein riesiger griff ins klo,
kriegt man auch glaube ich nicht kommuniziert wieso die zugriff auf das mikrofon brauchen soll natürlich ultraschall ist er nicht hörbare schall kann man technisch herleiten aber.
Für die mehrzahl der menschen ist da zugriff auf das mikrofon etwas womit sie nicht rechnen und was sie eher skeptisch stimmt.
Und und das absolut berechtigt weil das ist ja tatsächlich eine verbreitete technik von so werbeträger gewesen die tatsächlich eben in apps mikrofon im hintergrund angemacht haben und darüber dies
überall trash schall ausgesendet haben also es ist tatsächlich schon als dreckigen methode von werbefilm benutzt worden und von daher
geht das halt gar nicht.
Also wie gesagt die an diese app ist entwickelt worden ende märz war dann die erste version die in die öffentlichkeit kam
und wir haben gleich am ersten april eine sehr umfangreiche analyse veröffentlicht und die fakten zusammengetragen das thema war von vornherein ein großer aufreger.
Wir haben halt einfach versucht drüber aufzuklären was es was tut diese app.
Was sind auch unsere forderungen dafür also wo wo es mal ganz klar dass es so nicht geht
diese fünf forderungen waren halt eben dass diese app im ersten release noch nicht open source war
dass die kommunikation nicht klar war was kann ich mir von dieser app erwarten dass es bei euch auch immer wieder so ein durchgesickert das ist ganz gefährlich wäre wenn dieser app dazu führt dass man sich in falscher sicherheit wiegt
und dann zum beispiel auf sinnvolle maßnahmen wie masken oder abstand halten verzichtet und gerade auch bei diesem automatically.
Also wenn ich im hintergrund einfach alle menschen mit denen ich in kontakt bin,
mit denen sozusagen die in den kontakt digital zu sichere nennen wie automatik wenn das nicht funktioniert wenn das irgendwie,
zum beispiel manche nicht erkennt oder zu viele erkennt.
Punkt drei war eben dass das hosting bei einer amerikanischen firma liegt und auch tritt dienste in dem fall google verwendet wurden,
wir sind hier in einem bereich wo es ganz klar kommentiert ist dass es um die amerikanischen sicherheitsinteressen geht weil die infektionsklausel in einem land ist ein ganz klares wirtschaftliches unter sicherheitsinteresse,
und forderungen vierundfünfzig einfach nur ein security und die veröffentlichung der datenschutz folgeabschätzung wir haben dann schon eine sehr,
laut geführte mediale debatte wo sich ganz viele leute und auch die opposition zu wort gemeldet haben,
ich war in der zeit ein bild also dem österreichischen pendant zu tagesschau da war es ganz lustig weil
linus und ich wir haben uns nicht abgesprochen vor diesen diesen interviews ungefähr um denselben zeitpunkt herum wo diese app debattiert wurden sind aber auf eine sehr ähnliche formel gekommen.
A dass wir nicht zu sinnhaftigkeit sagen können,
aber das das durchaus datenschutzkonform abbildbar ist wenn man es richtig macht und das war glaube ich ganz gut dass wir so eine linie gewählt haben wenn man das mit anderen eu-ländern vergleich zum beispiel frankreich was er so.
Ja oder nein war aber es war nie eine wirklich differenzierte debatte das nächste was in österreich kam und ich glaube dass
ich glaube dass in deutschland schon abgeschlossen ist war die debatte über eine staatliche verpflichtung also vor allem unser bundeskanzler sebastian kurz hat er geliebäugelt ob man diese app nicht verpflichtend machen kann
und inzwischen habe ich auch von vielen leuten die an dem projekt beteiligt waren gehört dass es
auch noch mehr funktionalitäten gab die man sich davon konservativer seite drin gewünschen hätte wo eben aber das rote kreuz gesagt hat na mit uns gibt es das nicht
und das hat dann eskaliert dazu dass der präsident des nationalrates also unseres bundestages,
gefordert hat am freitag das diese app jetzt verpflichtend werden soll dann hat man eben den kopf gewaschen und am sonntag hat er die gegenteiliger meinung vertreten und damit war das thema mehr oder weniger.
Von der politischen bühne also es wird schon auch position immer wieder mal im raum gestellt ob's jetzt nicht doch vielleicht verpflichtend kommt aber im grunde ist klar die app.
Wird freiwillig bleiben und kann auch nur freiwillig erfolgreich sein,
ganz klar es ist nicht vorstellbar dass überhaupt mal die polizei dinge kontrolliert die ich auf meinem smartphone habe vor allem nicht die app von einem privaten verein
das ist das österreichische rote kreuz und dann kann die polizei auch nicht kontrollieren wenn
menschen kein smartphone haben vielleicht keine kein datenvolumen haben um die app sich runterzuladen da kann man ja keine rechtlichen anforderungen dran knüpfen und auch wenn man das probieren würde ob die app dann am ende richtig verwendet wird ob
bluetooth eingeschalten ist oder ob ich nicht doch ein zwei handy habe das führt alles nicht zum ziel also es ist so ein schönes gefangenen dilemma wie eigentlich diese gesamte situation
dass man dann nur ans ziel kommt wenn man es so gut macht dass die leiter dem freiwillig vertrauen
wollen leider muss man auch sagen dass die debatte die in den letzten wochen geführt wurde zu diesem vertrauen nicht wirklich viel beigetragen hat,
es ging dann weiter.
Also unsere erste forderung war wie gesagt das ganze muss open source werden weil nur dann kann man dem vertrauen und dann.
Kann man an uns herangetreten am siebten april mit einem verschwiegenheitserklärung sozusagen wir sind noch nicht fertig mit dem dokumentieren des codes aber ihr könnt ihn haben ihr dürft ihn prüfen.
Und sozusagen eure meinung abgeben dazu um sozusagen das ganze auch vorzubereiten
wir haben dieses angebot dann gleich geteilt mit spa research einem security institut sehr uni nach einer gemeinnützigen gmbh die einfach so nochmal viel mehr expertise in dem,
technischen security-bereich haben und mit now your business der von max schrems um auch nochmal irgendwie schützenhilfe bei den
hardcore datenschutzrechtlichen fragen zu haben.
Haben dann dieses muss man auch noch sagen haben wir veröffentlicht ist auf unserer webseite und besagt mehr oder weniger nur dass wir den code nicht rausgeben dürfen.
Ursprünglich wollten die unser maulkorb geben haben wir uns dagegen gewehrt wir haben gesagt ihr kriegt den bericht,
achtundvierzig stunden vorher aber ihr habt keinerlei kontrolle darüber was da drin entsteht oder nicht und responsibility haben wir ihnen angeboten haben wir dann auch gemacht also es gab aber kritische sicherheitslücken die wir gefunden haben die sich auch nicht im bericht finden.
Ja dann haben wir.
Am neunten april den code bekommen und die prüfung ging los das war ganz lustig weil am selben tag war ich im im parlament auf einladung der spö als experte zu dem thema contact dressing apps
wir konnten sich da auch wieder so ein paar sachen nochmal einfordern die sie dann auch gleich nachgeliefert haben weil es war die versammelte parteienlandschaft da
und am endeffekt im zweiundzwanzigsten april haben wir dann den bericht veröffentlicht und was da drin steht man hat so,
empfehlungen die wir aufgestellt haben wo wirklich nachgebessert werden muss und sechzehn davon wurden gleich mit einem hotfix am selben tag gelöst.
Bei den verbliebenen zehn waren's drei die ende der aktuellen woche und vier in drei wochen gelöst werden und,
vielleicht kann man dazu mal kurz darauf eingehen was da technisch dahinter steht also es waren viele.
Kleine sachen viele rechtliche sachen auch die wir begleitet haben aber dann gab es eine kategorie von von gröberen problemen,
die einerseits mal warnt dass diese app es erlaubt hat.
Bewegungsprofile also offline zu machen sprich die die die ausgeschickt wurden war nicht so zufällig wie das in dem,
dezentralen modell ja zum beispiel diskutiert wurde aber ich glaube auch beim zentralen modell ist das angedacht dass ich ja zum beispiel nicht wenn ich in,
n v oder,
plätzen bluetooth aufstellen mir merken kann ob das jetzt dieselbe person ist die da morgen vorbei läuft und die gegen diese attacke wurde nicht geschützt das ist so einer der punkte die auch ende dieser woche erst gelöst wird.
Sie hatten.
Kurze frage.
Das heißt die generierten codes waren nicht zufällig oder haben sie oder heißt es die generierten kurz haben sich gar nicht die ganze zeit geändert.
Vielleicht ist es gut wenn ich mal erklären von welcher architektur wir hier sprechen also das rote kreuz oder century haben versucht eine dezentrale app zu bauen,
und sind aber daran gescheitert weil gerade dieser konzepte die wir heute haben mit definitiv und mit dem was google und apple in aussicht gestellt haben damals noch nicht zur verfügung standen
und die haben halt versucht das dezentral zu bauen die handys sollen sozusagen direkt miteinander was austauschen und und es ist so gemacht dass du eine asymmetrische verschlüsselung zwischen den geräten hast also wenn ich mich infiziert
melde dann verschlüsselt ich meine infektionsneigung mit den öffentlichen schlüssel der geräte die ich getroffen habe.
Weil in diesem hemd schick tausche ich die öffentlichen schlüssel aus zwischen den geräten ansich kein dummes modell.
Stößt dann gewisse technische limitierung an maßgeblich dass du halt so einen schlüssel nicht über bluetooth austauschen kannst ganz einfach weil die pilot bei bluetooth energy zu gering ist um diesen kompletten schlüssel zu übertragen,
und deswegen haben sie sich dann so diensten wie google hier bei oder bedient,
die natürlich dann wieder an zentrales element mit einbauen.
Und das ist natürlich extrem unschön so weil bei google ja bei was google da viel mehr als.
Du jetzt auch bei den dezentralen modell google wüste,
ist so eine schweizer bude mit einer datenschutz polizei zweitausendvierzehn denen will man auch nicht irgendwie den kompletten sozialen graf und infektionskrankheit geben also sie haben da viele
grundlegende fehler gemacht und deswegen haben sie jetzt auch angekündigt dass sie sofort auf eine dezentrale architektur wechseln werden.
Das ist einer der empfehlungen die dann eben jetzt in drei wochen gelöst werden sie haben sich da ein ambitionierten zeitplan gegeben.
Aber da haben wir halt auch gesagt so indem die architektur bringt gar nichts weiter zu machen ihr müsst da wirklich auf das was zeitgemäßes umstellen und.
Eben aber um auf deine frage zurückzukommen du hast sozusagen einen token den du über bluetooth austausch zwischen den handys,
mit dem token schaust du dann bei peer-to-peer-kredite am zentralen server nach was ist denn der öffentliche schlüssel zu dem gerät das ich gerade gesehen habe.
Zu dem server kannst du aber natürlich auch gehen wenn du ein bluetooth hast und dir die tokens einsam ist und hast du von dort dann einfach die public kies die eindeutig sind.
Dieses offline jackie da gibt's eine meditation die sie ende dieser woche online bringen wollen einfach eine keyword das heißt die öffentlichen schlüssel werden öfter getauscht sodass eben nicht eine langfristige beobachtung von von einzelnen geräten möglich ist.
Und das ist auf jeden fall wichtig weil,
einfach diesen angriff willst du nicht haben und der erlaubt ja auch unschöne dinge wenn du als arbeitgeber an deinem tür von der fabrik zum beispiel so etwas aufstellst und du weißt ob sich dann leute infiziert gemeldet haben,
das ist sowieso auch also,
dieses szenario ist glaube ich eines der der guten benchmarks bei all diesen systemen aber es zeigt dass das hier auch eben leicht gegangen wäre,
zweite großer bereich waren die statistik meldungen also wie gesagt sie haben versucht hat dezentrales system zu bauen,
ähnlich wie in der debatte in deutschland es gab dieses interesse,
mehr über die verwendung der app zu wissen mehr über die epidemie und die krise zu erfahren deswegen hat man statistik funktion eingebaut.
Und der weg in dem die verwendet wurde war aber so dass man sich wirklich in beide füße geschossen hat weil.
Ich habe da so einen schönen dezentrales modell wo ich gar nichts wissen will,
über den sozialen grafen wer jetzt wen kennt oder vielleicht wen infiziert hat und dann mache ich eine statistik meldung
anstellen wo es nicht tun darf zum beispiel wenn ich eine infektionsneigung entschlüsselt habe also wenn es ist so wenn ich mich infiziert meldet verschlüsselt ich das mit den leuten die ich getroffen habe,
und schickt diese meldungen an alle geräte.
Und nur die die den richtigen privaten schlüssel haben können die entschlüsseln und wissen ob sie jetzt betroffen sind schön gemacht,
so weißt du eigentlich nicht wer hat vielleicht wen infiziert hat wenn dann aber genau das gerät das jetzt ein funktionsmenschen entschlüsselt habe dem server das bescheid sagt.
Dann hast du dein komplettes konzept in die tonne getreten und da haben sie halt auch als hotfix diese statistik meldung sofort rausgenommen
was auch eine ein ein wichtiger erster schritt war weil das das wär's uns überhaupt nicht gegangen und wir haben ihn da auch empfehlungen gemacht,
wie man so eine statistik bauen kann ohne dass es rückschlüsse über einzelne erlaubt indem du halt nicht in dem moment wo du was entschlüsselt dich meldest sondern,
gesammelt einmal am tag machen dass alle geräte oder wenn du das mit der franchise privacy mit einem rauschen versiehst sodass du auch einfach mathematisch ausschließen kannst dass es noch rückschlüsse auf einzelne
geräte oder oder infektionskrankheiten geben kann ich.
Das sind vor allem für deutschland dann jetzt auch wichtige erkenntnisse weil wenn da jetzt eine telemetrie funktion anonymisiert mit eingebaut werden soll dann kommen wir genau solche fragen wieder auf.
Insofern ich glaube dass man also,
in keiner weise will ich sagen dass in österreich ja alles richtig gemacht wurde im gegenteil die fehler sind so offensichtlich dass man glaube ich viel davon lernen kann und wie gesagt das erlaubt einem auch einfach,
wieder dieses vertrauen muss in der architektur schon eingebaut sein dass du halt keine zeitlichen korrelationen machen kannst und.
Über die franchise privat sieht den rest ab handelt der problematisch sein kann.
Und ja insgesamt war die statistik funktion aber auch was das das man,
über den hotfix und über die konkreten lösungen ganz gut abgehandelt haben und dann gab's auch noch spezifische dinge die wir gefunden haben die in dieser architektur begründet waren,
wie gesagt das es gibt diesen server wo über alle infektionsweg ich mich informieren kann also die sind dann sozusagen.
Die die die die öffentlichen schlüssel sind sie aufschlag ausschlaggebend,
die werden in zweihundertsechsundfünfzig segmente zerteilt und ich kann sozusagen auch als dritter der.
Der app sich anschaut und den rauslässt zum beispiel aussagen darüber treffen,
ob leute mit denen ich einen handshake gemacht habe schon infiziert sind ich kann's nicht sagen so sind die infiziert aber ich kann mit sicherheit sagen dass sie nicht infiziert sind und das erlaubt dann so scenario das,
wenn wir was nicht zu zehnt auf einer corona partys sind alle viel zu nah beieinander aber wir machen alle die hinschickt und nachher kriegen wir alle eine infektionsneigung und da könnten wir nachschauen ob es zu einer
personen dieser gruppe keine infektionsneigung gibt und in dem design wer die dann in unserer gruppe gewesen weil man für sich selber wenn man sich infiziert
meldet natürlich keine infektionsneigung absetzt dass es ebenfalls so eine attacke an die nicht gedacht hat die.
Sie aber auch mit ende dieser woche mit einem weiteren release fixen wollen das zeigt halt einfach auch noch mal um die komplexität des problems.
Um die es da geht ja das waren jetzt nur mal so die technischen dinge.
Ich glaube dass da aber die reife bei difinitiv und vor allem auch bei google und apple vieles von dem problemen ausschließt,
aber trotzdem ist es natürlich für uns wichtig gewesen wenn man den sos-code schon haben wirklich durch die ganze linie durchzugehen deswegen auch die drei organisationen die alle ehrenamtlich,
komplett unentgeltlich diese arbeit in sehr kurzer zeit gemacht haben um einfach mal alle fakten auf dem tisch zu legen,
und wie gesagt es hat uns auch einen guten politischen hebel gegeben dass sie dann wirklich auch unseren empfehlungen folgen was sie was sie auch,
in allen punkten gemacht haben lustigerweise mit einer ausnahme im rechtlichen bereich.
Und zwar das wird das ist auch generell wichtig für das thema contact racing apps und noch in deutschland anders diskutiert worden als bei uns und.
Es ist so dass es in der datenschutzgrundverordnung auch eine anforderung gibt das daten richtig sein müssen über mich.
Und die frage ist wenn ich jetzt eine eine meldung absetze über diese app sind diese daten dann auch wirklich richtig wenn das.
Mir eine du bist potenziell infiziert meldung gibst dann ist das ein sensibles gesundheitsdaten.
Und da ist halt die frage inwieweit müssen die richtig sein in deutschland wurde glaube ich immer diskutiert dass man seine meldung nur abgibt wenn ein,
positives ergebnis vorliegt in österreich ist es nicht der fall bei der app des rücken kreuzes gibt es drei meldungen.
Eine symptome basierte meldung die ist gelb und dann eine positiv meldung rot und eine entwarnung grün.
Ich kann vor allem auch in regionen wo ich gerade einfach nicht genügend tests habe und das ist die mehrzahl der länder deutschland ist hier mit abstand am besten gesegnet was viele tests und test geschwindigkeiten angeht in den meisten regionen dieser welt ist der zugang zu tests
noch viel schwieriger als in deutschland und deswegen sind so symptom basierte meldungen ein wichtiger bereich.
Die das rote kreuz kommentiert das auch so ja wir haben uns da ja beschwert sozusagen dass das erlaubt.
Vor allem weil sie sie haben so gemacht mit einem formular in der app wo du dich wirklich nur selber befragt ja fühlst du dich gut ja nein.
Und wenn du nein sagst du hast du fieber oder hast du husten eins von beiden mit ja beantworten und schon bist du als potenziell infiziert gemeldet
und das war max und mir ein bisschen eine ziel zu niedrige hürde und,
wir haben das dann auch wirklich mit den epidemie vom roten kreuz diskutierten die haben gemeint doch doch genau das ist gewollt
weil in der container zwei null strategie auf die wir jetzt zugehen also wenn wir den look dann wieder öffnen wird es wieder zu mehr infektionsgefahr kommen.
Und die idee ist ganz einfach dass man diese vollsperrung dies zwangsweise geben wird in kauf nimmt und
österreich hat eine bevölkerung von neun millionen menschen annähernd und es wurde gesagt wir nehmen lieber neuntausend quarantäne in kauf anstatt neun millionen in quasi quarantäne.
Das ist die,
argumentation von von der fachlichen seite das kann ich auch nicht bewerten wir hätten es trotzdem logisch gefunden wenn man zumindest über eine hotline dieses symptome
abfragt und dann kriegt man token dass man sich mit der abkacken melden kann es wäre auch potentiell für die
person die so eine meldung bekommt hilfreich wenn sie weiß das ist jetzt nur eine symptom meldung und die person wird in vier tagen ein test resultat haben und das bekomme ich auch mitgeteilt
lässt sich über die pipette machen das ist so einer der punkte wo auch noch,
unser import diskutiert wird aber ich glaube dass mehrere formen von meldungen ganz hilfreich sein können weil wie gesagt tests werden auf absehbare zeit eine begrenzte
ressource sein und contact tracing kann auch außerhalb dieses forschen halses sinn machen und wenn ich das das weitere problem ist auch ein zeitliches.
Das eine ist das eine probleme seine test zu bekommen und dann die resultate rechtzeitig zu bekommen und erst wenn ich den habe und der positiv ist kann ich anderen leuten bescheid sagen wenn ich auf basis des symptome auch schon,
eine gewisse risiko einschätzung anderen menschen mitteilen kann habe ich einfach einen zeitgewinn weil es ist ja schon sowieso schon so dass auch bevor ich symptome zeige ich schon infektiös sein kann,
und wenn man da wirklich sozusagen erst auf den,
getätigten test wartet kann es sein dass die person die jetzt die meldung bekommt vielleicht selber schon am anfang der symptome ist.
Und theoretische auch wieder sofort leiten bescheid sagen muss bevor die die sie vielleicht auch schon angesteckt hat.
Also das ist dass es sicherlich etwas wo so eine app auch nur dann sinnvoll sein kann wenn sie in ein nationales gesundheitssystem und in einer test strategie integriert ist das ist so,
ein ganz spannender punkt glaube ich den man die man diskutieren muss.
Da vielleicht mir kurze anmerkung dazu weil,
also das hat eine wünschenswerte geschichte wäre dass man so ein ich fühle mich nicht so gut aber ich habe noch keinen test ich mache schon mal eine warnung um zeit zu gewinnen dass das so an sich wünschenswert ist kann ich gut nachvollziehen.
Allerdings bedeutet das natürlich auch dass man in dieser,
du musst ja auch verhindern dass das system einfach folge die wird mit irgendwelchen leuten die weißt du es gibt einfach leute die wollen immer alles nur kaputt machen warum auch immer und mit denen muss man natürlich auch rechnen und wenn es sozusagen eine einfache möglichkeit,
dieses system in irgendeiner form und wenn sie auch niedrig angelegt sind mit solchen warnmeldungen vollzupumpen dann werden sie das einfach tun es sei denn es gibt halt irgendein filter
es wird sich aus meiner perspektive,
kaum vermeiden lassen dass jede meldung egal wie sie jetzt gemeint ist also nicht unbedingt jetzt bestätigte infektion sondern eben vielleicht auch dieses ich fühl mich nicht so gut aber ich konnte mich nicht testen lassen muss in irgendeiner form,
durch eine zweite instanz moderiert werden,
auf irgendeine art und weise ja und wenn's nur eine telefon-hotlines ist die man anrufen muss und man muss denen das erstmal kurz erzählen und vielleicht auch.
In irgendeiner form sich.
Ja vielleicht nicht ausweisen aber also man muss sozusagen mal klar machen dass er sozusagen wirklich ein anliegen ist und dann dann erhält man quasi für diese eine meldung eine freigabe in form irgendeiner tan
so fünf buchstaben oder so sowas wäre schon macht aber natürlich dieses ganze melde gewesen auch nochmal komplexer außerdem ist es so doch letzte anmerkung.
Wenn.
Man ein regime in place hat wo ein test sehr schnell möglich ist was ja durchaus denkbar ist ja wenn ein test sehr schnell möglich ist dann ist es halt von ich fühle mich nicht so gut bis zu ich bin getestet sehr kurzer weg.
Und die tage davor hast du ja keine symptome.
Ja also ich kann nur sagen wie es hier jetzt vom roten kreuz gemacht wurde und der weg den die gewählt haben ist über natan sms also auch wenn du den fragebogen in der app so ausfüllst dass du zu der symptom meldung kommst,
musst du deine telefonnummer angeben die tanne eingeben und hier ist auch klar eine geschäftsbedingungen dass man missbrauch nachgeht,
und du wirst ja auch kontaktiert vom roten kreuz wende jetzt glaubst du hast korona dann musst du natürlich aktiv werden und dann dann musst du auch geholfen werden und im moment ist es so dass es.
Bisher glaube ich keine einzige meldung von missbrauch gab ich habe nochmal nachgefragt und es sind zumindest so auf der,
leitungsebene von den anderen weil das war auch einer der punkte die wir von dem verständnis ja wissen wollten und es kam schon allein mit dieser tat zu keinem trolling also ich weiß dass es in deutschland immer das hauptargument ist was genannt wurde aber
unsere daten haben jetzt
dieses problem nicht bestätigen können solange du halt so einen minimalen schutz hast und eine telefonnummer anzugeben dir in österreich ja dank sind registrierung auch nicht mehr anonym ist hat gereicht um das abzufangen.
Ein weiterer punkt der vielleicht noch ganz spannend zu diskutieren ist was heißt denn das eigentlich wenn ich so eine meldung in der app bekomme.
Weil dann dann habe ich eine potenzielle gefährdung und ich kann auch ansteckend für andere sein und.
In österreich gibt es zumindest an tatbestand im strafgesetzbuch die fahrlässige gefährdung von menschen durch übertragbare krankheiten
das ist ein fahrlässigkeit delikt also das heißt da brauche ich jetzt noch kein
ganz konkretes wissen es es reicht eine wahrscheinlichkeit es gibt hier in österreich auch schon rechtsprechung vor allem von der schwulen community high-end-bereich wenn man auch gar nicht positiv getestet ist auf hiv aber,
eine lebensführung hat die in die richtung geht dann eben kein kondom verwendet könnte man schon unter diesen fahrlässigkeit tatbestand fallen.
Und da das sind natürlich auch fragen der gewährleistung und der haftung wenn ich so eine meldung in der app bekomme.
Und mich da nicht daran halte wie ist es rechtlich einzuschätzen und einer der punkte die wir gerade diskutieren ist ob man hier rechtlich.
Das ab das klarstellen sollte und möglichst technologie neutral halt auch die erwartungshaltungen wenn man diese app verwendet und sich daran hält oder nicht.
Dass das an eben auch helfen kann ein weiterer punkt den wir rechtlich jetzt gerade noch irgendwie versuchen durchzuboxen,
freiwilligkeit ist schön und gut also wenn es kein gesetz gibt dass die app verpflichtet aber das hilft dir natürlich nicht wenn zum beispiel dann modehäuser oder hand anfangen die verwendung der app in ihrer hausordnung reinzuschreiben.
Oder arbeitgeber verlangt das oder eine airline wenn sie wieder mal fliegen darf verlangt dass die passagiere so eine app installiert haben.
Und der einzige weg unserer meinung nach wie man das sauber rechtlich ausschließen kann,
über das diskriminierungsfreie wenn du die app als diskriminierung anführst sodass halt,
auf basis dieser der verwendung der app du nicht vom zugang
zu dienstag oder künstler oder dem der arbeitswelt ausgeschlossen sein darfst
das erreicht ziemlich genau das was man hier haben will und schafft auch wiederum rechtliche klarheit und es ist auch die freiwilligkeit
stärkt weil ich glaube im endeffekt und das ist auch wichtig für die gesamte debatte die wir hier führen wenn wir wirklich eine hohe durchdringung mehr als die hälfte der bevölkerung dieser app nutzen muss damit wirklich an,
haben kann dann dann führen wir die debatte gerade so dass wir gerade massiv boden verlieren also in österreich merkt man.
Dass auch menschen die bereitwilliger und facebook und weiß gott was alles verwenden sich super über diese app aufregen und.
Dass da sozusagen auch so ein so ein bauchgefühl dahinter ist wenn es um gesundheit geht dass man besonders vorsichtig ist.
In wirklichkeit ist es unumgänglich dass man so eine app in absoluter transparenz und und und und offenheit entwickelt,
dieses vertrauen in der bevölkerung was ein ganz rares gut in dieser krise ist nicht frühzeitig verspielt.
Was ist denn jetzt die rolle also,
sehe ich das richtig so ich hatte jetzt so berichte jetzt so interpretiert dass man dadurch dass man eben wie du schwer schon geschildert hast mit dem bisherigen ab ansatz einfach ein bisschen an der technischen realität der smartphones gescheitert ist und
da eben nicht unbedingt die zukunft sieht ist jetzt das so dass wenn man jetzt auch auf und damit auf das apple google modell schnell umsteigen wird.
Dass es eben teil von unserem bericht gewesen so einer der forderung war die architektur werde ich in diesem ziel bringen steigt gleich auf das datenschutzfreundliche für die definitiv oder ähnliche datenschutzfreundliche um und,
dir ist man nachgegangen also wir haben die zusicherung vom roten kreuz dass sie das tun werden
das soll eben auch in drei wochen ende,
über über übernächste woche soweit sein man glaubt doch dass das realistisch ist ich weiß nicht auf was sie sich da berufen aber extension ist groß genug,
sie wahrscheinlich in der lage sind damit apple die infos zu bekommen für ihren eigenen entwicklungsprozess.
Die app ist inzwischen auch open source das habt ihr in der letzten sendung schon gesagt jetzt müssen sie halt liefern und wir werden da weiter ein kritisches auge drauf haben.
Ich weiß nicht ob das zur duschen essen ist und ob wir uns jetzt irgendwie von technik was versprechen was sie nicht leisten kann.
Aber den datenschutzbereich ich glaube das sind wir auf einem wirklich guten weg jetzt in in österreich und in deutschland.
In anderen eu-ländern schaut es noch weniger gut aus.
Ja und ich denke auch meine ist ja immer die frage eine glas halbvoll und so wie man das so sieht ich bin ich bin überzeugt davon dass hier noch viele fehler gemacht werden,
so und das ist in gewisser hinsicht auch in ordnung solange es sich dabei um um fehler im klassische fehler handelt also das richtige angestrebt,
aber auf dem weg gestolpert ist was ganz anderes als von vornherein vollkommen falschen weg einzuschlagen und dann auch,
alle zeichen am straßenrand zu ignorieren dass man doch vielleicht vor der schlucht mal umdrehen sollte also das wird auf jeden fall passieren nur.
Kann man natürlich jetzt auch eine menge lernen und selbst wenn uns das auch noch in den nächsten zwei monaten nicht hilft,
kann es durchaus sein kann sein dass wir hier sehr schnell an neuem wissen gewinnen das auch,
smartphone anbieter entsprechend nachbessern ja wenn sich irgendwas als praktisch herausstellt was was ich diese symptome meldung dass man das in irgendeiner form diese fremdwort noch mit.
Einbettet es werden sich auch erstmal bestimmte melde prinzipien durchsetzen müssen man wird erfahrungen damit sammeln sagen okay so haben wir uns das eigentlich gedacht aber funktioniert nicht wegen,
keine ahnung bürokratischen realitäten gesellschaftlichen akzeptanz nicht verfügbarkeit von irgendwelchen ressourcen etcetera dann wird man halt wieder umsatzes also es wird auch vermutlich noch ein paar mal umgebaut werden.
Aber ich denke es kann hier fortschritt gemacht haben zumal wir eben ein vielleicht erstmal datenschutzrechtlich,
problematische situation haben dann geht das jetzt mehrere funktionen in einem in einer app oder in einem set von apps vereinigt werden nämlich diese
benachrichtigung über die jetzt so viel gesprochen wurde also das eigentliche contact tracing dann eben diese teilnahme an statistiken in irgendeiner form
dass man vielleicht über so eine app auch generell sein gesundheitszustand liefert so wie das ja in deutschland mit dieser datenspuren app gemacht wird oder dass man eben auch diese quarantäne begleitung hat,
was ähnlichen bereich reinläuft aber man an der stelle vielleicht in eine anonymisierung explizit sogar noch aufgeht bis hin zu weiteren funktionen die sich jetzt vielleicht noch gar nicht so unmittelbar
zeichnen bis hin zu so einem so einem gesamtfigur thermometer für für die gesamte gesellschaft und dann.
Dann dann wird die debatte nicht einfacher aber ich halte es durchaus für was erstrebenswert ist weil am ende erhalten wir unter umständen ein.
Ganz kataplexie werkzeug um einfach so 'ne pandemien zu widerstehen was wir so überhaupt niemals vorher gehabt haben.
Absolut und ich ich find's auch wichtig dass ihr europa hier wirklich einen einen grundrecht endlichen weg zeigt weil,
gesagt hast technik wird eine zentrale rolle in der bekämpfung dieser krise spielen das haben wir in asiatischen ländern schon gesehen.
Europa muss die region sein die das richtig macht und zwar so richtig wie's geht.
Machen wir doch da an der stelle gleich mal eine neue kapitel marke auf und und und rollen wir mal explizit diese internationale perspektive rein ist denn in österreich auch schon mit deutschland gesprochen worden ist oder in der schweiz ist sozusagen über ein roaming schon mal irgendwie gesprochen wurden von diesen meldungen.
Eine gute frage ursprünglich war das ja irgendwie das kredo von per petty dieses roaming einbauen zu wollen und ich glaube bei definitiv und google apple ist das auch.
Möglich oder zumindest ja also sollte auf jeden fall meiner meinung nach ein einer der faktoren sein.
Wir wollen ja irgendwann auch mal wieder die freizügigkeit zurückhaben und diese scheiß grenzen ignorieren.
Und im moment ist es auch also die debatte ist auf jeden fall in den europäischen institutionen angekommen.
In der letzten folge habe ich ja noch begleitet dass die eu so zurückhaltend ist und dass wir nur national auf eine globale krise reagieren.
Es gibt inzwischen eine klare aussage der eu-kommission dass ein dezentraler ansatz für contact tracing datenschutzfreundliche ist die kommission hat sich auch generell mit recht guten communications auch auch nicht nur zu dem thema bisher zu wort gemeldet.
Wir haben das european protection board also der datenschuss aller datenschützer sodass barack des datenschutzes die auch sagen daten minimierung ist wichtig zumindest mal in der fußnote.
Im europaparlament ist es auch so dass so grüne linke und liberale eigentlich schon dann starkes auge auf den datenschutz haben.
Wenn man die die an die in die länder schaut so spanien schweiz und niederlande haben eine klare präferenz für dezentrale konzepte.
Österreich war jetzt eben.
Mittwoch letzte woche mit mit diesem rote kreuz hat sich da positioniert deutschland war am freitag italien haben wir am samstag gedreht,
italien ist jetzt auch verfechter eines dezentralen ansatzes wo es noch wirklich gerade es kalibriert ist frankreich.
Morgen dienstag das müsste der achtundzwanzigste april sein wird im französischen parlament abgestimmt über contact tracing also ursprünglich wollte man eine abstimmung haben zwischen zentralen oder dezentralen system.
Hintergrund wer die debatte verfolgt hat so innerhalb von peppi und bei den befürwortern des zentralen ansatz
haben sich die franzosen mit dem mit der radikalsten position bisher geäußert ich finde das so schon fast wieder lustig wenn man so in den eigenen
standard dokumentieren so freut sich ein schlecht bei dem modell das die franzosen vorgestellt haben gibt's zu den zentralen ort weiter an dem das smartphone sich wendet.
Dafür haben die franzosen das symbol eines panoptikum genommen ich fand das sehr passend für das was dieses system auch irgendwie technisch mit,
und auf jeden fall es gab da massive proteste innerhalb von marge der partei von emmanuel macron.
Und er wurde sozusagen zu dieser abstimmung gezwungen.
Moment schaut aber so aus dass sie über einen prozentualen trick einfach über die gesamte lockerung der bisherigen maßnahmen inklusive der app abstimmen und hat eben keine demokratische entscheidung ob zentral oder dezentral passieren wird dort.
Die debatte in frankreich ist auch eine dass man sagt ja wenn google und apple das jetzt irgendwie unterstützen dann kann es ja nur schlecht sein und deswegen dürfen wir uns auf keinen fall darauf einlassen.
Die debatte wird dort auch leider nicht so differenziert oder lösungsorientiert geführt.
Auch von der zivilgesellschaft nicht was ich schade finde weil es gibt hier halt einen enormen spielraum technologisch was für modelle man unterstützen kann.
Und ja es wird spannend wie das morgen ausgeht.
Aber das ist nicht ist in deutschland auch nicht unbedingt immer besonders gut gelaufen ja dass also die beiß.
Reflexe in solchen debatten sitzen sehr tief inklusive einem wunderbaren beitrag von jasper von alten bochum niemand der.
In deutschland publizistisch tätig ist hat einen besseren namen
einen namen der besser zu dem passt was und wie er schreibt ja also dicht gefolgt von don alfonso der ja auch sehr klar schon durch den namen ausdrückt was man da zu erwarten hat jasper von alten bochum hat.
In einem beitrag in der faz geschrieben der chaos computer club sollte sich jetzt nicht gegen die
lösung von google und apple stellen ne also ganz klassische vorurteile ja das ist dann irgendwie darum geht so der chaos computer club ist immer für datenschutz und wenn dann das heißt der chaos computer club steht immer im weg
und apple und google sind immer gegen datenschutz und deswegen
wenn die beiden sich zanken dann müssen wir jetzt auf dem chaos computer club eindreschen ja dann habe ich da habe ich darauf hingewiesen zu sagen so.
Der chaos also darf ich folgendes formuliert habe ich gesagt der chaos computer club,
setz dich doch für die lösung von google und apple ein korrekte formulierung wäre natürlich gewesen chaos computer club und google und apple schlagen die gleiche lösung vor ne das wäre jetzt so.
Weil weder google noch apple noch der chaos computer club haben sich das ausgedacht sondern spezifisch wurde es.
Denke ich der ansatz am in der wahrscheinlich höchsten reife von,
drei formuliert und wer ihn sich ausgedacht hat ich weiß noch nicht mal mehr wer daran die urheberschaft haben kann ja daraufhin hatte ich dann die leute an der backe die meinten der chaos computer club will jetzt auf einmal apple und google empfehlen ja und das sind halt alles so.
Also es ist sehr erstaunlich in solchen debatten zu sehen.
Einfach nur interessant ja von der analyse her welche begriffe,
beim menschen so dazu führen dass sie halt sofort absolut rot sehen und datenschutz tätet
ist einfach das ding was jetzt hier noch viel weiter gekocht wird auch deswegen freue ich mich dass in deutschland diese debatte jetzt erstmal beigelegt wurde.
Arbeiten kannst auch davon ausgehen dass in der nächsten generation ja wenn jetzt noch mal irgendein konflikt kommt dann wird es dann wird.
Uns in anführungszeichen ja die irgendwie für dezentralität und datensparsamkeit einstehen genau das um die ohren geworfen werden also sollte es jetzt zu dem nächsten problem kommen und sollte ich es wagen.
Ja
dazu nochmal was zu sagen oder der chaos computer club nochmal irgendwie sich öffentlich zu äußern dann wird es halt heißen der chaos computer club der war doch jetzt gerade noch zufrieden
jetzt ist es auf einmal nicht mehr der muss sich auch mal entscheiden solche dinge das wird ja dann alles kommen während du jetzt streng genommen wir alle ja.
Immer sagen was war schon immer gesagt haben nämlich das was war schon immer gesagt haben und das war das schon immer gesagt haben naja.
Tja wenn dir erstmal draufkommen dass es alles eigentlich immer meine privaten wünsche sind die nur vom dem c sozusagen der welt erklärt ne dann dann dann ist alles.
Hier einfach unsere unsere sichten einfach den anderen aufoktroyiert.
Das dürfen wir keinem sagen linus ja.
Ich habe so schöne e-mails leute meine inbox.
Halte ich ein bisschen zurück weil wir müssen noch ein wenig über die,
dimension reden jetzt haben wir gehört wie es in frankreich ist ich fasse mal zusammen schwierig machen wir mal die landkarte soweit voll wie wir das derzeit wissen also die schweiz ist dezentral österreich wird dezentral deutschland mit dezentral estland
haben sich glaube ich schon zugesagt italien hast du genannt und spanien auch.
Okay gut dass es noch news tommy sprich da tut sich schon was und über kurz oder lang ist doch eh klar oder sollte klar sein oder wäre es ja zumindest wünschenswert dass man einfach mal sagt okay hier europa macht es jetzt so,
und so kooperieren wir.
Ja das wäre wünschenswert ich meine gegenteilige ansatz ist wenn man sagen es ist ein neues problem vielleicht sollten wir nicht am,
alles auf eine karte setzen und länder können auch mal andere wege ausprobieren norwegen ist ganz spannend die haben schon eine app die ist zentralisiert.
Löst das problem mit dem background auf iphones darüber dass sie einfach mit location daten so eine approximale machen also in eine annäherung ob das jetzt ein kontakt war oder nicht auch wenn die app schon in den hintergrund gefallen.
Der ab sofort geht das wahrscheinlich auch da wenn er drei kilometer.
Der wind könnte das dahin geblasen haben bei der bevölkerungsdichte muss man das vielleicht anders modellieren norwegen und dänemark sind insofern auch spannend weil die,
beide gerade auf einem zentralen ansatz setzen und das testing dort
ist auch wirklich an die nationale oder eben an die telefonnummer mit sim-karten registrierung geknüpft das heißt da ist das contact racing und die labor ergebnisse wirklich,
sehr leicht zusammenzuführen.
Nein die haben auch eine andere datenschutz kultur in nordischen ländern kannst du nachschauen was irgendwie dann der nachbar der nachbarin vom steuerausweis zurückbekommen hat aber.
Finde das schon auch ein bisschen extrem an der stelle.
Aber die haben halt einfach ein ganz anderes vertrauensverhältnis an der stelle also das ist muss man einfach auch sehen ne aber klar.
In
kroatien und der slowakei ähnliches also der contact racing wurde noch nicht irgendwie eine entscheidung getroffen meines wissens nach aber halt auch so mobilfunk daten und über die wege versucht man es jetzt hat gerade also das passiert nicht in der app sondern zentralisiert,
haben auch extra gesetze gemacht und versuchen sozusagen auf basis der mobilfunkes jetzt dieses contact waxing zu machen.
Also es gibt auf jeden fall verschiedene ansätze und ich hoffe wird dir auch vergleichen können,
im moment wirkt mir die kommission hier auch sehr aufmerksam wir verlinken noch ein eine ganz gute studie des wissenschaftlichen dienstes europaparlaments zu dem thema und auch ein webinar der liberalen fraktion,
im europaparlament zur contracting wo auch google und apple und der michael will von einer der hauptfiguren von definitiv zu wort kommen das ist sehr spannend also da hat man wirklich nochmal die debatte auf hoher ebene.
Auch mit den relevanten leuten der großen tech-konzerne ich glaube da kann man einiges draus ablesen.
Ich glaube auch das war so alles was ich jetzt aus dem kopf und mit dem infos von meinen kolleginnen über europa sagen kann,
wenn ihr hier dinge vermisst die in ländern die euch nahe sind gerade passieren dann schreibt es doch vielleicht auch in die kommentare wir versuchen da grade auch so ein bisschen überblick zu behalten.
Also es gibt glaube ich in habe ich aber jetzt auch nur am rande mitbekommen gab es auch so debatten zwischen und google et cetera also auch da war sozusagen diese debatte mit sonderwünschen schon am
kochen ich würde aber einfach mal,
erwarten so aus so einem kulturellen betrachtung dass sich auch in relativ schnell dieses apple google modell etablieren wird aber es kannst jetzt gerade noch mit keinem link belegen werde ich auch nochmal,
verfolgen ich denke wir werden jetzt in den nächsten zeit ohnehin mal mehr quer über europa schauen müssen und dann natürlich auch wie sich die kommission dazu verhält die sicherlich jetzt nicht einfach irgendwas beschließen kann weil wir sind ja hier auch wieder in einer interessanten
politischen situation wo wir eigentlich ein gesamteuropäischer problem haben was aber eben mehr als jedes problem zuvor in der geschichte der europäischen union.
Erstmal national angegangen wird grenzen zu und,
ausschließlich nationale regime hat mir ja auch schon mal besprochen kai auch nachvollziehen kulturelle gründe sprache vertrauen als diese ganzen sachen nur ist ja auch klar,
irgendwann muss ich das eben wieder auf diese europäische ebene verlegen und mittelfristig natürlich vor allem auch auf eine internationale ebene und das denke ich sollten wir hier auch noch weiter.
Begleiten.
Also ich ich ich fand's nochmal bei dem webinar ganz spannend weil da hat eine europaabgeordnete auch nochmal google und apple explizit gefragt ob sie nochmal auf eine zentrale architektur umschwenken würden und die haben das kategorisch verneint.
Und insofern ich glaube dass es mal abgefrühstückt wir sollten uns auch um andere themen aus der bei der apps kümmern jetzt ich glaube da gibt's viel in dieser krise noch zu besprechen.
Und vielleicht ist der drops gelutscht ich hätte noch ein paar kleine news aus österreich.
Wer war mal österreich österreich ist aber übrigens auch europa.
Ja ja noch exit ja im grunde wollte ich nur eine kleine,
zusammenkehren was so passiert ist in den letzten wochen ich war glaube ich um zwanzigsten märz das letzte mal in der sendung und ich die die schlagzahl der netzpolitische relevanten dimensionen ist doch,
bezeichnen und deswegen gibt es ein paar vielleicht ganz spannende sachen also.
Ich weiß nicht ob das in deutschland auch so ein thema war aber wir haben ja viele die maßnahmen des lok down sind bei uns wirklich über
gesetze verordnungen oder alesse wirklich auch in den gesetzesbrüche es gibt tägliche pressekonferenzen der regierung und die polizei prüft auch
sehr viel von dem wie sich leute verhalten also wir haben so fälle von menschen eine strafe bekommen weil sie auf einer parkbank sitzen und andere menschen zu nahe an ihnen vorbei gehen
und teilweise wird dann
auch gestraft auf basis von dingen die in pressekonferenzen der regierung gesagt wurden die sich aber so nicht in den erlassen oder gesetzen finden,
und das war hat einen punkt erreicht dass wir jetzt eine neue kampagne gegen polizei willkür gemacht haben vor sich leute melden können.
Ihren fällen und wir versuchen die aufzubereiten wir machen das nur in österreich aber ich glaube es ist an der zeit dass man auch da wieder so ein kleines feedback zirkel einfordert weil ja teilweise schon so gewisse.
Macht phantasien in der exekutive vorherrschen was man jetzt hier den leuten alles verbieten sollte und ich sehe das als sehr problematisch an.
In deinem logbuch frei hat sicherlich auch schon eine ganze menge drüber diskutiert.
Ich wollte gerade hier schon darüber sprechen ja das ist ja eine sehr großartige gelegenheit die aktuelle folge von logbuch freiheit zu empfehlen über.
Ding dong klick subscribe glocke.
Genau glocke bingo über polizeigewalt und racial profiling.
Wo wir uns genau damit auseinandergesetzt haben und bei der gelegenheit auch nochmal etwas zu,
zu berlin in berlin gab es jetzt gestern eine fahrrad demonstration ja also das war so ein bisschen das thema von logbuch freiheit nummer eins
wie die versammlungsfreiheit
gewahrt wird wahrgenommen wird ja und das ist hat sich ja das gespräch mit hupen neugebauer über neue ideen der.
Des politischen protestes unter korona sicherheitsauflagen und da gab es gestern in berlin eine fahrradtour.
Die sich gegen das ging den umgang und die aufnahme oder die gegen den umgang mit den geflüchteten in lagern.
Richtete und da sind dann also kleingruppen rad gefahren ja mit politischen willensbekundungen und da war auch ein paar laver ja da schießt auf einmal die polizei rum und verfolgt irgendwelche leute die irgendwie mit fünf leuten fahrradfahren oder so.
Da kommt das auf jeden fall gerade wirklich zu absurden szenen.
Und was ich sehr interessant finde nur
weil man vielleicht grundsätzlich sagt dass es vielleicht eine ganz kluge idee ist hier ein paar sicherheitsmaßnahmen einzuführen um eine pandemien vielleicht ein bisschen in kontrolle zu halten ja ist es heißt es nicht dass man diese polizeimaßnahmen gut heißt,
und da finde ich sehr gut wenn sich da jetzt langsam das augenmerk darauf richtet auch der und.
Insbesondere eben missbrauch von polizei macht haben wir in logbuch freiheit behandelt fand ich eine der.
Bisher gelungenen vollen.
Cool dann verlinken wir doch wer in österreich irgendwie da betroffen ist oder von fällen hört polizeikontrolle epicenter dort works.
Einfach zu merken der e-mail-adresse kann man sich hinwenden es gibt ein team von leuten auch mit touristischer ausbildung die die fälle prüfen.
Und wir haben leider nicht die ressourcen so richtig rechtsberatung zu machen aber bei einzelfällen überlegen wir uns schon dann auch zu den höchst gerichten zu gehen,
da gibt's eigene prozessfinanzierer um halt auch irgendwie,
den rechtsstaat nicht ganz vom tablet fallen zu lassen weil ich ich ich finde es wichtig dass man sich jetzt immer noch im grundrechte kümmert und dass das in dieser krise erst recht wichtig ist ich meine der staat will ja dass wir ihm gerade vertrauen.
An dieses vertrauen ist nicht geschenkt.
Wenn wir von von rechtsstaat reden es gibt auch noch irgendwie ein paar infos die wir nur verlinken ebenso wie die justiz umstellt der jetzigen situation.
In den meisten ländern was er eh schon so dass das justizsystem eher personell schlechter ausgestattet ist und natürlich sind physische verhandlungen in der jetzigen situation ein besonderes risiko.
Und da haben wir uns auch die regelungen in österreich näher angeschaut was da jetzt auf einmal möglich wird es ist,
leider ein bisschen peinlich oder oder lustig also es gibt natürlich zoom im haupteinsatzbereich in den ganzen gerichten mit all den sicherheitslücken dort,
und keinerlei technische vorgaben wenn man jetzt zum beispiel verfassungsrichter entscheidungen treffen dann könnten die theoretisch eine gruppe machen oder eine whatsapp-gruppe und so zu ihren urteilen kommen das wäre jetzt rechtlich zulässig.
Und da da ist halt leider noch nicht so wirklich durchdrungen das ist hier natürlich auch sehr hohe anforderungen an vertraulichkeit und zuverlässigkeit der der werkzeuge geben muss.
Wir haben auch irgendwie breit diskutiert sms warnsystem also wenn über eine spezifische region.
Ein eine quarantäne verhängt wird oder andere maßnahmen,
erlaubt der staat sich jetzt irgendwie den leuten sms zu schicken da haben wir auch irgendwie am gesetz mitgearbeitet und geschaut dass da keine vorratsdatenspeicherung über die hintertür kam.
Und wer weg von zum will ihr habt es gibt auch mal einen schönen vergleichs- mit anderen lösungen vor allem auch datenschutzfreundliche rennen.
Weil das das das so ein unsicher ist glaube ich würde jetzt hier auch schon breit diskutiert.
Und das sind so die wichtigsten themen bürgermeister bekommen in österreich jetzt die information wer in ihrem dorf oder ihrer stadt.
Karona positiv ist dass es etwas das dass wir auch kritisiert haben wir haben's wenigstens geschafft dass die.
Bürgermeister zum ersten mal strafen zahlen müssen wenn sie diese daten zweckentfremden also wenn sie sich nicht an das datenschutzgesetz halten bisher war so in österreich dass die öffentliche hand nicht bestraft werden kann.
Das ist jetzt das erste mal dass man auch als.
Staatliche stelle sozusagen risiko und kosten zu befürchten hat wenn man sich nicht an den datenschutz hält.
Wir haben es nicht geschafft dass komplett zu verhindern zweigen wie eine lustige debatte weil wir hatten eigentlich ein gutes argument das bringt doch nichts wenn man jetzt irgendwie das argument was so essen auf rädern und ähnliche dienste müssen wissen wenn sie zu leiten hingehen ob die infiziert sind oder nicht.
Und wir meinten so ja aber sie sollten sich doch bei allen schützen und nicht nur bei denen die positiv getestet sind.
Anderen war die reaktion ja aber wir haben nicht die schutzausrüstung um uns dauerhaft zu schützen wir können's nur irgendwie bei zwei von dreißig besuchen am tag machen.
Das war das reale argument was dann von regierungsseite kam an der stelle.
Ja da muss man natürlich kurz einhaken das ist ja also unabhängig von unter umständen.
Einem mangel an diesem schutz ja.
Ist es ja auch eine tatsache dass diese schutz nicht den ganzen tag tragen kannst,
unter der annahme dass du tatsächlich einer corona positiven personen begegnet bist musste das ja dann tauschen und das ist ja ein relativ ausführlicher prozess.
Ja das ist ja einer der gründe warum in den krankenhäusern da diese strikte trennung stattfindet damit du damit du nicht den ganzen tag von einem anderen zimmer gehst und dich dann nochmal umziehen muss dass ich will nur sagen das argument.
Ist ein problem dass der die problemschilderung ist eine das heißt aber natürlich trotzdem nicht,
diese veröffentlichung und sonstige von infektionsstation auf einmal in ordnung ging und das sollte eigentlich jedem klar sein erinnert mich an diese diskussion die wir in deutschland haben mit der polizei.
Ja also ich bin in südkorea wurden die daten ja wirklich auch veröffentlicht also hier genau an die adresse gab es einen fall an das ist auch sehr drastischer schritt,
der glaube ich so in europa nicht denkbar wäre.
Ich habe aber auch die befürchtung wenn das irgendwie die bürgermeister innen in manchen kleinen dörfern sind wo man sich halt kennt das kann schon zu sehr unschönen situationen führen
also ich glaube dass dieses diese krise wird uns noch so lange beschäftigen und gleichzeitig,
ja die die wenn man die debatte lösungsorientiert führt und jetzt gerade wo wir in den schritt kommen dass wir langsam wieder aufsperren.
Dass wir uns auch eine perspektive darüber machen wie es die nächsten wochen und monate ausschauen wird der gestaltungsspielraum war noch nie so hoch.
Leider im guten wie im schlechten aber ich glaube schon prinzipiell dass wenn man die debatte offen und lösungsorientiert hält das dann durchaus noch.
Gute sachen möglich sind also ich habe jetzt zumindest noch wenig leute erlebt die wirklich so ihren special place in hell beanspruchen und privat oder ideologisch irgendwie versuchen persönlichen gewinn aus der situation zu ziehen.
Berlin treffen die sich glaube ich auf einem rosa-luxemburg-platz oder so da haben wir jetzt schon.
Da haben wir sie schon sitzen ja und da gibt's übrigens ein artikel im tagesspiegel wo der.
Klaus lederer bisschen.
Denke ich mal einen ganz guten ehrlichen einblick in das regierungshandeln und die entscheidungsfindung hier gibt
aber so ein bisschen sagst du ja also titel ist wir sind in mancher frage zu weit gegangen ist er natürlich auch klar dass,
das dann da eine kurskorrektur stattzufinden hat.
Und gleichzeitig weiß ich natürlich auch daraufhin die wissen ja eher mehr auch alle ist ja auch von denen die erste pandemien und das da gibt's.
Kann ich nur wiederholen das gefällt dann wieder einigen nicht im moment in deutschland niemand sagt es gibt keine schwierigkeiten.
Sie haben sie ja grade angesprochen polizeiliche maßnahmen datenschutz diskussionen und sonstiges aber so alles in allem,
so so wenn man mal so insgesamt sagt ne wir leben immerhin in einem land wo wir nicht.
Diskutieren müssen ob wir uns jetzt.
Hier desinfektionsmittel spritzen und uv-b rühren einführen das ist schon erstmal alles ganz gut und hier kann auch nur jeder sagen was er möchte und.
Das heißt nicht dass die probleme die wir haben nicht bekämpft und ich beseitigt werden müssen das tun wir ja hier auch eigentlich mit sehr großer regelmäßigkeit aber,
diese verschwörungstheorien die da jetzt irgendwie sich immer weiter entfalten das ist sicherlich keine keine keine aufgeklärter umgang mit dieser situation.
Gerade wenn du verschwörungstheorien sagst.
Hast du übrigens also außer natürlich wenn der bill gates uns jetzt schippen will ne also wenn der bill gates uns chippen will dann hört der spaß auf und diese fünf masten müssen auch ausgeschaltet werden.
Was masken auch das doch.
Ich will eine fünf g maske.
Ich auch.
Das kann man mal vorne drauf drücken.
Masken jetzt haben wir auch noch eine fünf masken pflicht.
Alle abbrennen.
Gut
ja ich habe echt überlegt dass das nimmt so überhand also die fünf verschwörungstheorien waren vorher schon
sehr bedenklich aber jetzt dass die fundiert richtig in alle gesellschaftsschichten aus also die menge an wirklich grün verschwörungstheorien die einem so aus.
Aus breiteren sozialen umfeld also leute die man kennt zugeschweißt werden die nimmt merkbar zu also ich glaube schon dass.
In dieser total verrückten situation in der wir gerade sind sich immer mehr menschen ihre fakten halt aus.
Ihre alternativen fakten aus irgendwelchen alternativen medien holen.
Ich denke wir sind am ende der sendung angekommen wenn ich das mal so einwerfen darf.
Ja war wieder schön dabei sein zu können.
Das war so schön dich da gehabt zu haben hasi.
Jederzeit wieder.
Lass mal kurz auf die checkliste gucken ich habe für den youtube-kanal geworben thomas hat aber noch nicht für spenden geworden.
Ach ja ich mache das so ungern ich wurde so nicht erzogen.
Ja
Machen wir das für dich also epic works sitze ich in österreich für das überleben aller ein und deswegen dürft ihr diese organisation auch weiterhin unterstützen,
link ist in den shownotes genau und.
Wer wieder erwarten von der ganzen app diskussion nicht genug kriegen kann schaltet diese woche wieder bei lkws ein da geht's weiter.
Wunderbar hat mich gefreut bis zum nächsten.
Dank und bis zum nächsten mal tschau tschau.
Tschüss.
Aux